absolute value is a very very simple
idea okay but then again some of you
know better than others that sometimes
simple ideas can give birth to very very
deep implications and complicated you
know ramifications so yes you can went
unfinished so let me define for you what
absolute value is I'm gonna give you a
variety of definitions they go from sort
of simplest most common sense and then
I'm gonna sort of filter down into more
complicated abstract definitions okay so
here's my first definition definition
number one okay definition of one
absolute value and this is kind of where
the name comes from is the positive
value of a number that's it the positive
value of a number that is the simplest
definition I can give you okay so the
examples what does this mean if I say
what's the absolute value and here's the
notation for you it's two Vaughn lines
kind of like parallel lines you know
it's like those two markers but separate
it out the absolute value of five that's
how I read that out is equal to five
oh my blowing I told you I'm stopped at
this point okay let's go again
how about the absolute value of negative
three now I just want the positive value
of that okay so therefore it's three
when you are first introduced to
negative numbers in the topic of
integers in you seven okay we call
integers another name for is directed
numbers directed numbers and this idea
is important because it explains that
numbers they start from just counting
right I'm thinking how big is something
or how much of it do you have but then
it expands this idea that numbers are
not just about quantity
or value or size they can go in certain
directions okay
integers can go in one of two directions
positive or negative okay so another way
of saying this is what's the positive
direction equivalent of whatever number
you're giving
okay so positive value number that's
pretty simple you can put these together
operations it's not that complicated
let's think about this for example let's
do 3 minus 3 minus the absolute value of
negative 1 by the way this is something
that should have been mentioned to you
throughout your your years since you
learn what integers are okay but there
is a difference between this minus sign
and this minus sign even though
informally we kind of say 3 minus minus
1 right and we'll even call that minus 1
minus is an operation it says do
something right but here like this
negative number is negative number
they're actually meant to be adjectives
not verbs it's it's trying to describe
that number and in fact your calculators
even distinguish between these if you
get your calculators out now your
calculators actually had a negative
button on them you should find it at
least on mine it's on the left hand side
it's a minus sign a hyphen in the pair
of brackets okay so when you put that on
you might see you get a short - as
opposed to the minus which is a slightly
longer one it's like two whole pixels
longer on my screen okay
so there's a minus button and a negative
button now because so many people don't
really get that there's a difference
your calculator if you if you put -
where you should have put negative
you'll kind of get what you mean okay
but let's try now because it's so
important to this idea let's try to be a
bit more specific and accurate with our
language well the difference is not all
that much there if for example I just I
haven't tested this but if I go three
and then negative one it'll say syntax
error because negative is not an
operation right you need an operation
between two numbers and three negative
one it has there what's the theme
between them so for example you could
say 3 minus negative 1 and that
give before as you expect it was it for
all right so now tell you that to this
so I'm going to read this out as three
minus the absolute value of negative one
okay it's a simple example so we'll just
like any other kind of brackets
we're just go from the inside out three
- what's the absolute value of negative
one one so this is - no big deal okay
that's definition number one